je suis vanné sacré dans ce cliché 42
ans je suis surveillant du palais de
pigeons 2019
notre principale mission donc
surveillons du palais là sur terre
intrusion pour remplir notre mission
nous devons être postés à chaque entrée
du palais et ses dépendances
notre but est de contrôler l'entrée des
piétons et des véhicules
nous autorisons ou interdisons l'accès à
telle ou telle personne en fonction des
consignes de sécurité
notre rôle est particulièrement sensible
étant donné le public qui fréquentent
l'institution ça peut être les membres
du gouvernement les parlementaires les
oublis ou bien aussi les journalistes de
ce rôle est d'autant plus important
compte tenu de la menace terroriste
qu'il ya actuellement en france il y a
aussi des manifestations contre lesquels
il faut protéger le sénat il faut savoir
conjuguer cette qualité d'accueil et ce
public
ces populations sensibles tout en
restant ferme sur les règles d'accès
agir avec discernement être attentif
remonter tout événement inhabituel à
notre hiérarchie sont les qualités
demandées un surveillant du palais la
sûreté intrusion passent eux aussi ont
la surveillance de nuit d extérieur du
palais mais aussi de ses dépendances
nous disposons pour cela de caméras de
4000 points d'intrusion nous devons
tourner 365 jours par an mais aussi 24
heures sur 24 est prêt avec un garde
républicain armée à répondre à tout
déclenchement dallas je m'appelle
richard idiot je suis surveillant du
palais de 800 mo et je travaille au
sénat depuis le 1er janvier 2014
les surveillants du palais ont également
pour mission d'assurer la sécurité
incendie du palais et de ses dépendances
avec ses quatre minutes expert incendie
la surveillance exercée 24 heures sur 24
365 jours par an sur une surface totale
de 110 mille mètres carrés de locaux
parmi les quatre mille deux cents pièces
recensés une grande partie d'entre elles
ont une valeur historique avec la
présence d'oeuvres d'art en cas de
déclenchement de la détection incendie
les surveillants des palais effectué une
levée de doute ils font appel à la
brigade sapeurs pompiers si nécessaire
nous vaut plus un rôle de prévention que
d'intervention sur les départs pour flo
néanmoins afin de limiter les risques
incendie du sénat ni habits sont
quotidiennement les autorisations de
permis feu les contrôlons les chantiers
à l'aide de caméras thermiques
cette mission de prévention de sécurité
incendie exige une connaissance parfaite
de la topographie des lieux afin
d'intervenir le plus rapidement possible
et de guider la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris le cas échéant
bonjour je m'appelle mec bachelard j'ai
40 ans je suis surveillant du palais
depuis deux ans les surveillants du
palais ont pour mission la protection
des personnes et des biens au sein du
sénat et de ses dépendances
à ce titre nous avons notamment en
charge le secours à personne nous
intervenons pour tous types de des
presses malaises chutes et blessures
avec un public très variés tels que les
sénateurs les fonctionnaires les usagers
du sénat mais également tous les
visiteurs qui accède au palais nous
assurons une première prise en charge
des personnes
et si nécessaire nous contactons la
régulation médicale du samu afin de
transmettre un bilan et en cas de besoin
de demander le renfort des secours
extérieurs ou éventuellement un moyen de
transport médicalisé
néanmoins le support à personne n'est
pas notre activité principale mme
effectuant qu'une centaine
d'interventions par an afin de garantir
notre savoir-faire en disposant d'une
équipe de formateurs de premiers secours
qui assurent au quotidien le maintien
des acquis des surveillants notre
service détonnants également un agrément
délivré par le ministère de l'intérieur
nous proposerons aux fonctionnaires qui
en font la demande des formations telles
que les gestes qui sauvent ou le premier
secours cible de n'y voir
[Musique]